En este vídeo, ¡amigos de VisualPolitik,
vamos echar un vistazo a la trayectoria de
quien, casi seguro, es uno de los personajes
más controvertidos y sorprendentes de
lo que llevamos de siglo.
Hablamos de Mijail Saakashvili.
Un momento, ¿no le conoces?:
Pues... imaginate un personaje que es al mismo
tiempo, uno de los mejores aliados de Washington
y el mayor enemigo de Vladimir Putin.
Un personaje capaz de haber sido presidente
de un país, aspirante a la presidencia de
otro y que hoy carece incluso de nacionalidad
alguna.
Un hombre, un político, un personaje propio
de novelas de intriga, política y misterio.
Un tipo, amigos, cuyas hazañas parecen parte
de un guión para alguna súper producción
de Netflix.
De hecho, ahora que lo digo, no me extrañaría
nada que se acabe haciendo algo así.
Pues bien, todo esto es nuestro protagonista
de hoy, Mijail Saakashvili.
No es la primera vez que le mencionamos, aquí
en VisualPolitik.
Hablamos sobre él en uno de nuestros primeros
vídeos, uno que hicimos sobre la Revolución
de las Rosas.
Por cierto, en la descripción os dejo el
enlace.
Desde luego aquellos vídeos eran un pelin
diferentes a los de ahora... estábamos empezando,
así que ya se sabe… y desde luego, por
aquel entonces esta comunidad de VisualPolitik
era mucho, muchísimo más pequeña.
¡Cómo han cambiado las cosas!
Así que, ante todo, muchas gracias a todos
los que estáis suscritos a este canal y hacéis
posible que este proyecto crezca y crezca.
De verdad, ¡Gracias!
Pero... dicho esto, volvamos al bueno de Misha,
que es como se conoce a este personaje, y
al que muchos consideran como la mano política
de Washington en el antiguo... espacio soviético.
Vamos allá.
(MISHA, EL GOBERNADOR)
Para comenzar nuestra historia tenemos que
remontarnos hasta el 30 de mayo de 2015.
Ese día, Petro Poroshenko, el Presidente
de Ucrania, nombró a Mijail Saakashvili gobernador
de la provincia de Odessa.
(Junto al puesto de gobernador, a Misha se
le concedió la nacionalidad ucraniana, algo
para lo cual, Saakashvili tuvo que renunciar
a la de su país natal, Georgia, cuyos destinos
había dirigido entre 2004 y 2013.)
El  fichaje  fue toda una bomba mediática.
Y... no era para menos.
Veréis, en aquel momento Ucrania vivía un
estado de tensión enorme.
Tras la llamada revolución del Maidán y
la caída del Presidente prorruso, Victor
Yanukovich, acontecimientos de los que ya
os hemos hablado en este canal, el país vivía
una situación prácticamente de guerra civil
entre los partidarios de Kiev y los partidarios
de Moscú.
Y Odesa era, precisamente, una de las provincias
más prorrusas.
Así que ya os podéis imaginar, amigos, que
eso de fichar a todo un expresidente extranjero,
tratándose, encima, de uno de los mayores
enemigos de Vladimir Putin, fue un acontecimiento
que copó espacios en todos los medios de
comunicación.... del planeta.
El presidente de Ucrania - antiguo compañero
de Universidad y viejo amigo de Misha, por
cierto, Petro Poroshenko - lo calificó en
aquel momento como “el hombre que hace posible
lo imposible”.
Menudo piropo ¿verdad?.
Y es que, en aquel momento, el idilio entre
ambos parecía a prueba de bombas.
Pues bien, la misión era estabilizar Odessa,
apuntalar el poder de Kiev, perseguir la corrupción
y poner los cimientos que permitieran que
la región prosperase.
(Para hacer todo ese enorme trabajo ,Misha
trajo consigo a muchos de sus antiguos colaboradores
en Georgia;
se rodeó, también, de muchos profesionales
jóvenes ucranianos a los que consideraba
limpios de corrupción, como por ejemplo,
Yulia Marushevska una activista que se hizo
famosa precisamente aquí, en YouTube, con
el vídeo Yo soy ucraniana.)
Y, además de todo esto, Misha hizo incluso
algún que otro fichaje entre los opositores
de Putin en Rusia, como fue el caso de la
activista rusa, Maria Gaidar, que ocupó el
cargo ni más ni menos que de Vice-Gobernadora.
Había mucho trabajo que hacer y había que
hacerlo pronto, así que… dicho y hecho.
Nada más ponerse al frente de Odessa, Misha
puso en marcha una investigación minuciosa
para encontrar y castigar a los funcionarios
corruptos;
cambio a prácticamente todos los mandos de
la administración; simplificó el proceso
para crear empresas,
introdujo controles independientes e incluso liberó para el uso público playas
que habían sido ocupadas ilegalmente.
Y, ojo, porque Misha tiene una curiosa forma
de trabajar, tan efectiva como polémica:
si algo no funciona y es corrupto, lo disuelve,
echa a todos los trabajadores y lo vuelve
a montar de nuevo.
Lo hizo en su tiempo como Presidente de Georgia
con la mismísima Policía de Tráfico, y
amenazó con hacerlo de nuevo en el Puerto
de Odessa, el mayor puerto comercial de Ucrania
y que era conocido por los sobornos y los
pagos a los funcionarios de aduanas.
(“Tenemos que despedirlos a todos.
Tenemos 130 nuevas personas.
Son jóvenes y están bien entrenados.
En los de antes no hay ninguna esperanza”).
Al final, solo tuvo que despedir a algunos
responsables del servicio de aduanas para
que se frenase la corrupción, Fijaos:
(“Varios empresarios señalaron que los
sobornos en el puerto realmente se habían
detenido en los últimos meses, principalmente
porque la gente tenía miedo de convertirse
en la próxima víctima de la guerra contra
la corrupción de Saakashvili.)
Con tanto cambio y gracias, por supuesto,
a los contactos del nuevo gobernador, Odesa empezó
a recibir ayuda de Estados Unidos.
Y como Misha no se fiaba de la policía lo
primero fue montar una especie de nueva policía
independiente para luchar contra la corrupción.
Una policía organizada y entrenada por el
mismísimo FBI.
Vamos, que nos puede parecer que todo iba
viento en popa ¿verdad?
Pues... esperad un momento...porque lo cierto
es que Saakashvili y su equipo pronto se dieron
cuenta de que todo iba a ser mucho más difícil
de lo que habían pensado.
El problema, amigos, es que Odessa no era
un campo de batalla entre seguidores de Kiev
y prorrusos...
sino en un campo de batalla entre el estado
basado en la ley, y el estado de los grandes
oligarcas que han dominado Ucrania desde su
independencia.
EL REINO DE LOS OLIGARCAS
Cada vez más expertos lo tienen claro: el
mayor problema de Ucrania, su mayor obstáculo,
no es Rusia… sino los oligarcas.
Ucrania, amigos, es algo así como un país
donde la corrupción está tan arraigada que
casi podemos hablar de una especie de país
feudal donde los nobles son, por supuesto,
los oligarcas que lo controlan todo: las empresas,
el poder político, la Administración, los
medios de comunicación…
Prácticamente nada escapa a un poder que
han consolidado a base de dinero y miedo.
Su grado de impunidad es, prácticamente,
total: incluso policía, gobierno y jueces
forman parte de esta especie de juego.
Esto, amigos, lleva siendo así desde que
Ucrania alcanzó su independencia, pero a
partir de la Revolución del Maidán, las
cosas empeoraron.
(Tras la caída del presidente prorruso Viktor
Yanukovich y ante el estado de conflicto civil
que vivía el país, el nuevo gobierno se
vio incapaz de confiar ni el ejército ni
en la policía, dos instituciones corruptas,
desorganizadas y mal equipadas.
Por eso, tomó una decisión: nombrar a varios
oligarcas gobernadores de las regiones más
vulnerables del país.
Estos oligarcas financiaron un ejército privado;
pusieron a la policía bajo sus órdenes con
generosos salarios y pusieron precio a la
cabeza de cada separatista.)
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis.
El gobierno puso a los mafiosos directamente
al frente de varias gobernaciones.
Fue el caso, por ejemplo, de Ihor Kolomoisky que fue puesto al frente
de Dnipropetrovsk, una de las provincias económicamente más importantes del país.
Sí, esta es, amigos, la Ucrania, que se encontró
Mijeil Saakashvili.
(“En Ucrania no hay una sola empresa estatal
que no haya sido usurpada por un clan u otro”.
Aivaras Abromavicius, Ministro de Economía
y Comercio de Lituania.)
Cómo os podéis imaginar todos estos oligarcas
no recibieron con manos abiertas a ni a
Misha ni a su plan de reformas:
Una vez, incluso, le echaron de una entrevista
de televisión cuando sugirió que había
que encerrar a todos estos mafiosos.Recordad
que los medios son propiedad de los oligarcas
El caso es que Misha dio pronto batalla para
tratar de terminar con esta situación…
(“Haré lo que sea necesario para obtener
una victoria completa y librar a Ucrania de
esta inmundicia, de esta corrupta escoria,
que capitaliza la sangre de nuestros soldados
y cuya única motivación en la vida es llenar
sus propios bolsillos, fortalecer su propio
clan y sangrar a Ucrania hasta dejarla seca”
Mikheil Saakashvili.)
Y, dicho y hecho.
Misha empezó a denunciar públicamente y
sin tapujos todo tipo de tráficos de influencia,
tratos de favor y privilegios.
En una ocasión por ejemplo fue a la televisión
nacional y denunció con todo lujo de detalles
una corruptela que hacía que las aerolíneas
del oligarca Kolomoisky tuvieron privilegios
casi de monopolio en muchos vuelos del país.
La denuncia pública termino con esta situación
y llevó a varios implicados ante la justicia…
pero, claro, digamos que el señor Kolomoisky
no se lo tomó nada bien.
Prometió vengarse y esto lo que dijo públicamente
del gobernador Saakashvili.
(“Cuando un perro sin bozal muerde a alguien,
tenemos que castigar tanto al perro como,
más importante aún, a su dueño” Ihor
Kolomoisky)
Ahora bien, no penseis que Misha se limitó
a denunciar a los oligarcas… para nada.
(EL CHOQUE DE TRENES)
Las reformas de Saakashvili en Odessa no acaban
de dar resultado, muchas eran frenadas e incluso
saboteadas por el propio gobierno de Kiev…
Esto ya no era una cosa solo de los oligarcas…
lo cierto es que la corrupción en Ucrania
está tan extendida,amigos, que a veces cuesta
diferenciar entre las mafias y las propias
autoridades..
Misha no se lo pensó dos veces y puso al
gobierno, también, en su diana.
Muchos analistas dicen que en buena medida
esta nueva guerra contra el gobierno respondía
sobre todo a su ambición de dar el salto
a la política nacional.
Es probable que así sea, pero el caso es
que... lo hizo.
Comenzó denunciando en televisión la corrupción
del mismísimo primer ministro, Arseni Yatseniuk
siguió con varios ministros y terminó
con su amigo, el presidente Petro Poroshenko,
la persona que lo había puesto al frente
de Odessa.
(“¿Poroshenko o Yanukovich?
¿Qué más da quién les va a robar?
En una situación en la que el presidente
ampara a dos clanes: uno criminal formado
por asesinos de los años 90 y otro de corruptos….
Yo no quiero estar callado y estoy harto de
todo esto.)
El idilio entre estos viejos amigos no había
durado mucho.
Como hemos visto, Poroshenko nombró a Misha
gobernador en Mayo de 2015, apenas un año
más tarde la batalla estaba servida.
(Finalmente, a principios de noviembre de
2016, Misha presentó su renuncia como gobernador
de Odessa y montó su propio partido político:
el MNF.
Y, ojo, porque pronto superó los 20.000 afiliados).
Así es, el georgiano ahora quería dirigir los
destinos de Ucrania.
En sus propias palabras, su aspiración es
convertir a este desastre de país en toda
una superpotencia europea, ni más ni menos.
Pero, puede que os estéis preguntando por
la respuesta de Poroshenko y del gobierno
a toda esta campaña.
Pues mirad:
(En julio de 2017, aprovechando que Misha
se encontraba en EEUU el gobierno ucraniano
le retiró la nacionalidad del país y le
prohibió regresar.
De repente, Mijel Saakashvili se convirtió
en apátrida, es decir, en una persona sin
país).
Ahora bien, si pensáis que eso detuvo a Saakashvili,...
estáis... muy equivocados.
Mirad, cuando le quitaron la nacionalidad,
Misha se trasladó a Polonia,
hay que decir que en Europa del Este es un
personaje bastante querido, de hecho fueron
varios los países que le ofrecieron su nacionalidad…
pero... no, Misha tenía decidido regresar
a Ucrania.
Y eso es, precisamente lo que hizo.
A pesar de las advertencias de Kiev, el pasado
10 de septiembre rodeado de una multitud de
partidarios cruzó a pie la frontera entre
Polonia y Ucrania.
Las imágenes de cómo pasa sobre los guardias
fronterizos son… tremendas.
Por cierto, ¿Qué pensáis que hace ahora
que ha regresado?
Pues a pesar de encontrarse en una extraña
situación legal… Misha está de gira por
el país, de gira política, claro.
Ahora bien, dicho todo esto, hay una pregunta
que nos queda por contestar, y que estoy seguro
que muchos de vosotros os estáis haciendo:
¿Por qué Mijeil Saakashvili?
LA REVOLUCIÓN DE SAAKASHVILI
En 2003, Misha lideró un levantamiento popular
contra el corrupto sistema político georgiano
liderado por Eduard Shevardnadze.
Y ojo porque llegó a ocupar el parlamento
georgiano en lo que se conoció como la Revolución
de las Rosas.
(A partir de ahí se convocaron elecciones
y Saakashvili literalmente arrasó.
Comenzó entonces un vertiginoso proceso de
reformas, una fiera lucha contra la corrupción
y una política dura hacia Moscú que se convirtió
en un modelo para muchos países exsoviéticos).
Pero, amigos, de todo esto y también de la
leyenda negra de Saakashvili, de su parte
menos glamurosa, que también la tiene, os
hablaremos en otro video, aquí en VisualPolitik.
De momento, turno para tí: ¿Crees que Misha
acabará dirigiendo los destino de Ucrania?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like y suscribite
a VisualPolitik
Un saludo y hasta la próxima!!